[Music]
the russian invasion of ukraine the
iranian nuclear program the north korean
bomb and chinese expansionism in the
south china sea the world is ablaze and
military matters are once again at the
forefront of international politics
because vladimir putin's aggression
against ukraine is causing a huge
geopolitical earthquake no one trusts
the neighbor who rarely says hello who
shouts more than usual and is not
particularly friendly the nightmare
unleashed by the kremlin has reminded us
all that the unimaginable is entirely
possible so given the situation it pays
to be cautious don't you think we're
seeing it in europe where practically
all countries are announcing record
military investments for the coming
years from the smallest nations like
estonia to the largest such as germany
and this is a trend that we can also see
particularly clearly in the asia-pacific
region because i think it's fair to say
that lately china's relations with most
of its neighbors are not exactly at
their best
[Music]
china is becoming a superpower and xi
jinping's government has started to
become much more commanding on regional
issues but to what extent can its
neighbours rely on a country like china
what can they do to avoid succumbing to
the giant well that's exactly what
explains new stories like this one
asia's military spending up 2.8 in 2021
bucking 1.8 global drop growth slows in
region but expenditures resilient to
economic squeeze and of course now
following the war in ukraine even japan
has heard the warning bell and what does
this mean well just as it's happening in
europe most countries here are preparing
their accounts to increase their
military spending and take note because
at this point we have to take something
very much into account yes china has
become the great regional power in asia
pacific but its influence is not as
overwhelming as we might think at first
glance for example the chinese navy is
the largest and most powerful in the
region but it accounts for only about 30
percent of the area's naval tonnage in
other words there is competition and so
visualpolitik fans this time we are not
going to talk to you about the big
players from countries such as japan
south korea australia taiwan or china
itself no in this video we want to focus
on two new emerging military powers in
the asia pacific two that may still be a
long way from the first division but
whose situation in a few years could
change radically what exactly are these
countries destined to become the next
military powers in the region and just
how influential are they likely to
become could they be the counterweights
that will determine the future balance
of power between china and the west well
let's get into it
[Music]
take a look at this band
what you are looking at is the south
china sea with the main territorial
claims of the countries around its shore
as you can see it is a huge puzzle the
dispute over these waters is so crazy
that up to four countries are claiming
the same piece of the pie at exactly the
same time and the problem is that china
seems less and less willing to deal with
all this mess after all it is the
largest and strongest country in the
area so why not impose its will why not
take over all the territory it considers
its own and control all the natural
resources that these waters may hold
well do you know what that's exactly
what xi jinping seems to think and that
is precisely why the chinese government
is increasingly raising the tone and its
demands on these territorial claims of
course china's neighbours aren't sitting
idly by and they've said to themselves
we'd better watch out
the people's republic of china wants to
take the lead the problem is that its
neighbours are not willing to go along
with its criteria because it is one
thing for china to be the strongest
country and another for it to become a
dominant power so while between 2003 and
2018 china increased its military budget
by 621 percent vietnam increased theirs
by 687
and other countries such as indonesia or
thailand which increased theirs by 255
percent and 264 percent respectively now
want to step on the accelerator even
more
let's just say that in the face of
china's military escalation more and
more countries in the area have come to
the same conclusion if we don't prepare
ourselves this could end up disastrous
for us
[Applause]
an idea that the current russian
invasion of ukraine has proven to be
neither an exaggeration nor an unfounded
fear
china has fully militarized three
islands in the south china sea us
admiral says
vietnam builds military muscle to face
china
u.s seen bolstering military links in
southeast asia to counter china did you
imagine that vietnam for example the new
rising star was increasing its military
budget even faster than china itself
doesn't all this deserve its own visual
politic video well listen up
history that won't be repeated
vietnam knows all too well what it means
to face a foreign power throughout the
20th century it faced france united
states what can i say and also china
itself so if there's one thing the
vietnamese are clear about it's that
they have to be prepared for any
eventuality
[Music]
precisely for this reason the vietnamese
government included military
reinforcement as one of the fundamental
axes of its famous 1986 doi moy policy
to reform its economic system and
gradually adopt a model of state
capitalism similar to that of china it
included military reform among the
objectives because up to that time
vietnam's armed forces were more like a
series of fragmented ill-equipped and
poorly trained military groups with
little correlation amongst themselves
however the collapse of the soviet union
put the brakes on this change vietnam
was a very poor country and the soviet
collapse only made things worse so
military modernization had to wait
[Music]
nevertheless with the arrival of the new
country and its opening up to the world
the vietnamese economy began to undergo
a huge revolution to the point of
becoming one of the fastest growing
economies in the world as early as 2006
the 10th national congress of the
communist party of vietnam set the goal
of turning the country into a
full-fledged naval power both
economically and militarily
[Music]
vietnam has thus begun to equip itself
with relatively modern weaponry mainly
from russia although among its
inventories we also find south korean
anti-submarine frigates french
helicopters and israeli drones not to
mention an increasing amount of u.s
equipment because despite their history
relations between the united states and
vietnam have been growing closer in
recent years
yes vietnam is much poorer than china
and its military budget is still a
fraction of that of its northern
neighbor but if there's one thing
ukraine has proven it's that you don't
need to be the strongest if you have
certain capabilities and above all if
you get good friends
japan vietnam signed defence transfer
deal amid china worries
us vp kamala harris makes historic visit
to vietnam we all know that the vietnam
war has already shown what a trap this
country can be for a foreign power so
hanoi's strategy is to increase the cost
to china of trying to take over the
vietnamese islets in the south china sea
as much as possible this explains for
example its determination to make their
submarine fleet currently with six units
in service one of the strategic elements
of its defense it also explains why it
has devoted considerable resources to
reinforcing the defenses of the spratzly
archipelago where it has rocket
launchers and attack systems with
sufficient range to attack chinese
controlled islets and neutralize their
airfields and radar systems
this is not only a political or
territorial issue but also and perhaps
above all an economic one you see
vietnam is experiencing a huge economic
boom and more and more companies are
seeing it as a possible alternative to
china or at least as a way of reducing
their exposure to the asian giant so
it's not unusual to come across news
stories like this samsung invests 920
million in vietnam plant expansion apple
supplier foxconn to build 270 million
dollar plant in vietnam amid u.s china
tensions
lg display raises investment in vietnam
factory by 1.4 billion local government
the lego group announces plans to build
new factory in vietnam to support
long-term growth it is precisely for
this reason that controlling and
enduring the safety and integrity of the
waters through which vietnam exports all
these goods is fundamental for
continuing to attract foreign direct
investment but visual politics fans
vietnam is far from the only country
that is starting to move
[Music]
guns versus butter
[Music]
if there's one country in southeast asia
that aspires to become a major player in
the region it's none other than
indonesia the reasons the same as we
have already seen in the case of vietnam
the threat from china and the need to
ensure control of the waters through
which it's growing exports to the rest
of the world transit the fact is that
jakarta seems to have had enough of the
constant chinese military incursions in
its waters this explains why they have
wanted to put their foot down at the
very least make some noise in the media
indonesia's 125 billion air naval
splurge may mean 50 warships at sea in
the next two years amidst incursions by
china into indonesia's extended economic
zone defence minister parabolo sabantio
is looking for major investment in
military gear the new story is tricky
because it is a long-term investment
figure but these kinds of announcements
are a way of saying hey we are here and
over the next few years we're going to
take the military issue much more
seriously than we have done so far until
now military matters as in most of the
countries in the area had been secondary
and in fact the indonesian military
hardware is not only old very old but
also a large part of it is in a very bad
state
for example in july 2020 a 1970s landing
ship purchased from east germany sank on
them in 2021 they lost a 40 year old
submarine in torpedo practice resulting
in the death of 53 sailors what's more
accidents with trainer and light attack
aircraft are the order of the day
but now the idea is that all of this
will change among the materials that
could arrive in the coming years we find
equipment such as the french rafale
lacist versions of the usf-15 and the
new south korean kf-21 fighter in whose
development program indonesia is
participating but above all this
country's military strategy has a
priority the development of what is
known as a green water navy a term that
refers to naval forces specialized in
coastal defense which on one hand would
allow it to control the national
territory don't forget that we are
talking about a country that has more
than 17 000 islands and or the other
hinder any ambition that china might
have over them the idea is a bit like
what we have seen in ukraine a much much
stronger power is going to think twice
before daring to get into a hornet's
list like this
this is what is known as operational
psychological deterrence a strategy that
involves creating a maritime defense
that makes any enemy incursion have a
sufficiently high cost so that the
potential invader completely abandons
his plans in other words the cost to
benefit ratio does not pay off
but to better understand what is behind
this objective we can take a look for
example at the natuna islands 272
islands under indonesian control that
are nevertheless within the line of the
new points claimed by china these
islands also come with a gift it is
estimated that their sub-soil contains
trillions of cubic meters of gas in fact
the enormous amount of gas estimated to
be in place could turn them into one of
the largest gas fields in the world and
i repeat they are claimed by china as
their own i'm sure you now have a better
understanding of the indonesian
determination to develop this green
water armada as rapidly as possible the
idea is to equip 274 ships 10 air combat
squadrons and 12 new diesel submarines
among other equipment
indonesia looks to triple submarine
fleet after chinese incursions of course
there is also a problem many experts
point out that chinese precision guided
missiles along with other technological
advances such as drones themselves would
allow beijing to attack and mop up the
area before penetrating indonesia's
exclusive economic zone this is what is
known as war from home
be that as it may vietnam and indonesia
are two examples of emerging economies
that are now beginning to take this
issue seriously and keep in mind that
between the two countries they will soon
have more than 400 million inhabitants
and an ever-increasing economic
development in other words we are not
talking about a small potential now
let's take a look at this other map
remember what we were saying earlier
about the tonnage of naval forces in the
region china is becoming a superpower
but it is a surrounded power that would
struggle to achieve dominance look at
the map look at south korea japan the
philippines taiwan vietnam and indonesia
together they would form a kind of
security barrier capable of greatly
limiting china's ambitions and would
force china to pay attention to too many
different fronts that's why improving
the capabilities of vietnam indonesia
and the philippines can be so important
geopolitically especially when these
countries are forging closer ties with
the united states south korea and japan
as the case seems to be the game is far
from over the war in ukraine has spurred
the desire of all these countries to
improve their capabilities to avoid
becoming a future ukraine makes sense
doesn't it but now it's your turn which
countries do you think will be the
future military powers of the world how
far will china's power go will it become
a dominant power in the asia pacific
region how far will this military race
go leave us your impressions below in
the comments and if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like it and
subscribe to visualpolitik if you
haven't already done so thank you very
very much once again for being here all
the best i'll see you next time
[Music]
you